support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy okay so units and conversion
factor these are very very important to
problem solving in chemistry just in
general so much of chemistry is problem
solving that requires a solid
understanding of these units and
conversion factors very very very
important super important in fact that's
why I wrote that there okay so the first
thing that we need we need to know is
that measurements of any sort are made
up of two things first thing is of
course a number the second thing is a
unit or units okay so for example if I
someone asks how tall am I I i would
tell you i'm 61 okay so what does that
actually mean if I just say 61 that's
just numbers right but specifically
anyone you know who hears that
understands what I'm saying understands
that that means that I'm 6 feet oops
excuse me 6 feet 6 feet and 1 inch tall
right so I'm 6 feet 1 inch I could also
say that I'm 185 185 what 185
centimeters so here we have numbers and
units that tell you exactly what those
numbers mean okay so measurements have
not only a number but a unit as well you
can also have ratios of units right
doesn't have to be just just one unit
like centimeters or I could the six feet
one inch could also just spin 73 inches
but it could be a ratio of units like
how fast is that car going well that car
is going 60 km/h or a hundred or a
thousand miles per hour that'd be insane
but the idea is that that's a ratio of
units right 60 kilometers to everyone
our 100 miles per hour that's not I
don't know any cars you can go that fast
but the point is that you can have a
ratio of units the second thing you can
multiply divide and cancel units just
like you can with numbers
okay so let's let's multiply some units
here for an example thinking about the
volume of a cube so the volume of a cube
we just know its length times width
length times width times height right so
let's just say each each dimension right
because it's a cube is 10 centimeters so
we could take the 10 the tens and
multiply them 10 x 10 x 10 and the
centimeters and multiply them
centimeters times centimeters times
centimeters so the 10 is multiplied
through gives us a thousand and the
centimeters multiplied by each other a
centimeters cubed right senator meet one
two three centimeters so centimeters
cubed and so that's why the volume is
expressed in cubic centimeters in this
case we can also divide units right for
instance like in gas mileage let's say
you drove 400 miles on a 20 gallon tank
so how many miles did you get per gallon
you could take the 400 miles and divide
it by the 20 gallons and then you divide
those numbers and divide the units as
well so if you divide the numbers you
get 20 miles for every 1 gallon and you
have 20 miles per gallon which you can
express as mpg or you of course you
could write that as 20 miles per gallon
specifically 20 miles per one gallon
right that's a ratio of units and in
that case we're dividing these units the
miles are being divided by gallons now
you can also cancel units just like you
can cancel numbers so let's say the
question was if I get 20 miles per
gallon how far can i get with 80 gallons
so what i did here is I set it up so
that my answer would give me miles I
want to know how many miles I can go
right on 80 gallons so i put the 80
gallons out here and I want the gallons
to go away right because my answer is
not going to be not gonna have anything
to do with gallons it's gonna be in
miles how far can I get how many miles
can i drive right so i put the 80
gallons here and i'm gonna multiply it
by the 20 miles per gallon some people
already do this intuitively but don't
really think exactly about how these
cancel so here we have 80 gallons x 20
miles per gallon and it's set up so that
you multiply your own multiply 80 x 20
and divide that whole number by 1 and so
80 times 20 is going to be 1600
and the units I to get are just miles
and the reason why that happens is
because the gallon divided by the gallon
cancels those units cancel all that i'm
left with is just the miles there
alright so the next idea I want to talk
about is a conversion factor this is a
very important idea conversion factor is
a ratio that allows the ability to
express a measurement in a unit
different from the unit with what you
started okay that's mouthful basically
it allows you to convert one unit to
another right so let's say for example
those 1,600 miles that we just found
let's say we wanted to know how many
feet those 1,600 miles were how many
feet is that well I guess the first
question you'd ask yourself is how many
feet are there in one mile and the
answer that is that there's one mile one
mile is 5,280 feet okay so this this
here this one mile equals 5280 feet that
definition there this is probably
conversion factor equation and we're
going to turn this into a conversion
factor by doing what we have written in
orange over here the first thing is
divide both sides by 5280 feet so when
you when you have an equation whatever
you do to one side get to do it together
so we have one mile equals 5280 feet
we're going to divide both sides by 5280
feet so here one mile / 5280 feet equals
5280 feet / 5280 feet dividing both
sides by that value so what happens here
what happens here is that the on the
right side the 5280 feet here and here
cancel right the number cancels and the
unit cancels so five dozen hundred
eighty s cancel the feet cancel and then
we just get 1 over 1 which is just one
right so now we have one mile over 5280
feet equals one that's what we have
there okay now over here we could do the
same thing except divide both sides by 1
i'll instead so divide both sides here
by one mile what happens there
is that on the left side the one and the
one canceled or they stay there
depending on how you want to look at it
and the miles cancel so we just get the
number like 1 over 1 which is just one
right so again we have this one equals
five thousand 180 feet over one mile
these are called conversion factors this
is a conversion factor these guys here
that is a conversion factor that is a
conversion factor notice that one mile
because it's defined as 5280 feet or
that's like the definition in terms of
feet of one mile that equals 1 so this
value here this one mile this ratio this
ratio is the conversion factor the
conversion fetch is a ratio and this
ratio equals one so if you multiply any
number by one that number stays the same
right over here also this thing is this
is a conversion factor as well it's a
ratio and this ratio equals one right so
we could take this ratio and multiply it
by anything and it wouldn't change the
the value of whatever it is we're
multiplying it by it would only change
the measurement so this is super super
important so I just I'm going to repeat
what I just said by reading this white
portion here this means that if we
multiply something by this conversion
factor we're not changing the value of
the measurement only the unit's change
which is very very important that's the
whole purpose of these conversion
factors to change the units of something
without changing the value so and the
reason of course why it because
multiplying something by one just gives
you that something whatever you like it
bye-bye one so all conversion factors
equal one okay so the whole reason we
started talking about this is because we
said that we want to find out how many
feet those 1,600 miles were well okay so
I know that I'm going to use one of
these conversion factors but which one
am I going to use that's the question so
you're going to use the one that can
cancel the unit that you start with so
we're starting with these 1,600 miles
that's what we've drawn hito that's what
I've written here I want to convert
these 1,600 miles to feet so I want to
use the conversion factor I have to
choose between between i'll call this a
and i'll call this B which one am I
going to use
I want to use the one that will cancel
the miles so just going to have the
miles in the denominator or on the
bottom so this one has feet on the
bottom this one has miles I'm going to
use this one I'm going to use be so i'm
going to put 5280 feet on the top and
one mile on the bottom over here the
miles will cancel and now I just end up
multiplying 1600 x 5280 and then divide
by 1 that the one is really relevant
there in terms of dividing so what I end
up getting i end up getting eight
million four hundred forty eight
thousand feet right because the miles
canceled all that's left is the feet
unit right that has not cancelled so
that's how many feet there are in those
six 200 miles okay so we just used a
conversion factor to change the 1600
miles to feet this 88 million four
hundred forty eight thousand feet is the
same has the same value in terms of its
the same length as 1600 miles it's just
the unit has changed that's why
conversion factors are so important okay
so one thing that's important to note is
that using conversion factors to answer
questions or solve problems that that
sort of process is called dimensional
analysis okay so when you in analyze the
dimensions of things that's that's what
it's called and many many problems will
require conversion factors to be used
and some of them will be be used in
multiple steps so that's something that
you're probably going to see in future
videos and perhaps even in practice
problems that you have on your own so
it's important to keep track of these
conversion factors being able to
recognize what's going on with them is
very very important to successfully
solving problems in chemistry I did want
to note though that there are some
commonly used SI base units um SI stands
for system international it's written SI
and because it's actually in French I'm
not going to do a French accent or try
to pronounce it it's just the
international systems units these are
the base units that are that
that are for each of these dimensions so
length is the meter the little
abbreviation for the unit is VM mass
kilogram kg volume cubic meter meter
cubed right temperature Kelvin amount of
something is the mole that's something
that's actually pretty important all
this stuff's important we'll talk more
about it later the decimal prefixes for
the SI units are shown here in this
table you guys have probably seen some
of these these if you're if you're
watching this video it might be because
that you've stumbled upon this stuff in
class and you're trying to get some more
help on it these tables are pretty
standard here all these different
prefixes tell you basically how that
prefix relates to one so for instance
Millie is 1000 of one so if you have a
millimeter that's one thousandth of a
meter right whereas if you have a Giga
Giga meter that's 1 billion meters ok
and some of the ones that are used most
commonly I think are uh I'll I think
pico nano micro Millie senti not so much
desk I don't really see that very often
kilo mega those are pretty much the ones
that are used most often so this here is
really just just for completeness sake
you'll probably learn more about this by
doing practice problems as opposed to me
just talking about it okay so some often
important conversion factors I've
written for here they're definitely more
than just these four that are important
but it's just something came to mind
that when you're converting from miles
to kilometers is kind of connects the
standard English system to metric system
and this year I've written there's like
a curvy oil equal sign for this one and
actually for this one for the one
kilogram equaling 2.20 five pounds these
are estimates they're not exact values
there there should be more numbers here
and if you go further for the decimal
places is rounded off to the thousandths
place so so these are not exact values
however these two here have an actual
equal sign so these values are exact
these are exact values 1 milliliter is
one cube
centimeter that's a very very important
volume conversion factor and then the
inch two centimeters also that's very
very important especially as eyes an
exact measurement we'll talk more about
what exact measurements are and why
they're important later but I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful be sure
to video with the like and don't forget
to subscribe if you haven't already also
be sure to share the video with anyone
of you think might find it helpful
thanks and happy studying